[Music]
[Applause]
the whole thing yeah here we go here's
how the survey works we ask three
celebrities to complete a phrase our
first phrase was my favorite part of
planning my wedding was Anne Hathway
wrote choosing the perfect dress Busy
Philipps wrote writing my vows kim
kardashian wrote getting the script from
ii think one thing i bet you forgot
about me is Steve Martin wrote I can
play the banjo Gwyneth Paltrow wrote I'm
fluent in Spanish Rob Ford wrote I'm
also addicted to food I probably won't
see the movie Noah because Olivia Wilde
wrote it doesn't appeal to me David
crossroad I'm not very religious Larry
King wrote I was bullied by Noah in
you think Larry was on the art alright
Larry was on the art or did you just
swam for oh no no he was okay he was on
the ark with another Larry Q by 2 2 by
to read your Bible my favorite American
founding father is Greg Kinnear wrote
Thomas Jefferson
Steve Carell wrote John Adams John
Travolta wrote [ __ ] Valley Oh Franco
you're making friends left and right on
this show before every decision I asked
myself Matthew Broderick wrote am i
setting a good example for my children
Cheryl Sandburg wrote does this fulfill
my mission statement Vladimir Putin
wrote what would Bane do
if alec baldwin really wants to get out
of the public eye he should jeff
goldblum wrote stay away from Los
Angeles in New York Julie Bowen wrote
moved to the south of France Ryan
Seacrest wrote become a contestant on
this year's America
March Madness is my favorite time of
year because Norm Macdonald wrote I
enjoy the strategy of selecting a
bracket John Krasinski wrote I love the
thrill of college basketball Gary Busey
wrote it comes right before April
through February man
the biggest cultural difference between
America and China is Malia Obama wrote
the way men and women dressed the same
is just weird
Sasha Obama wrote some of their food is
just weird Chinese President Xi Jingping
wrote keeping two daughters is just
weird
[Applause]
[Applause]
if you see me at a home depot I'm
probably ty burrell wrote buying
something for the grill Malin Akerman
wrote buying garden supplies Bruce
Jenner wrote pricing the face Sanders
if Vladimir Putin does not pull his
troops out of Crimea I will be forced to
Ukraine president Alexander Churchill
wrote mobilize our nation's troops
Angela Merkel wrote called for a trade
and military embargo Barack Obama wrote
purse my lips even tighter no one ever
told me Gary Oldman wrote how the world
works Kevin Bacon wrote what to think
politically Shia LeBouf wrote when I was
supposed to take this bag on it seems
like every time I lie down for a nap Jim
Gaffigan wrote one of my kids needs me
Rebecca romaine wrote my phone rings
Wilford Brimley who wrote someone puts a
sheet on my head damn it I'm still
and finally I'm a mixture of tiger woods
wrote african-american Thai and Dutch
Vin Diesel wrote German English and
Italian Steven Tyler wrote pirate gypsy
and
[Applause]